Heads up, major Avengers: Infinity War spoilers
coming your way.
On top of having the most devastating ending
the Marvel Cinematic Universe has ever seen,
Infinity War has a pretty bleak beginning
and middle as well, full of goodbyes to favorite
characters right from the opening scene.
While audiences wait to see who returns to
finish the fight in Avengers 4, one performer
in the long-running series has just let people
know he's probably not coming back.
Idris Elba, the English actor who played the
Asgardian guardian Heimdall, bid a fond farewell
to his character on Twitter.
In the post, he wrote "#SpoilerAlert Gonna
miss my guy…Heimdall…"
The post seemingly confirmed that the keeper
of the Bifrost , who was among the very first
characters to meet their demise during Thanos'
assault, was one of the Marvel heroes we could
consider gone for good.
"I hope they remember you."
But regardless of what Elba says now, the
record seems to show that he's had anything
but a loving public relationship with Marvel
Studios.
As far back as Thor: The Dark World, Elba
was making delightfully unfriendly comments
to the media about how Marvel movies are,
quote, "torture", and how the indignity of
working on them, quote, "ripped [his] heart
out".
"Sorry about that."
Of course, with the central MacGuffin of Infinity
War being a magic glove that can turn back
time, there's no telling whether or not Elba
is truly going to be free from the franchise.
After all, Avengers 4 wrapped filming in January,
before Infinity War was even released.
Elba may have Heimdall in the rear view, but
that doesn't mean his character doesn't have
a scene or two in the fourth movie.
If the actor's Instagram is anything to go
by, Elba spent Infinity War weekend racing
single-seater Formula E cars in Paris, France.
Doesn't seem like he's too bummed about his
newfound freedom.
But if he does end up making a surprise return,
well,he wouldn't be the first Asgardian warrior
to come back to life.
Avengers: Infinity War continues to set box
office records, and the next movie in the
MCU series, Ant-Man and the Wasp, is set to
swarm theaters in early July.
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!